[Applaudissements]
au début quand je faisais des ateliers
de produits naturels ou même des
ateliers de cuisine aux algues
je pensais que je ne faisais que
apprendre aux gens la cuisine aux algues
ou à faire sa lessive ou ou son
dentifrice ou ses produits maison
mais en fait plus le temps passe et plus
je me suis rendu compte que je faisais
pas que ça que je faisais bien plus que
ça
fait je me suis rendu compte que quand
on faisait soi même ses produits
ton cuisiner soi-même ses algues
bretonnes bien sûr
lien on devenait plus libre parce que à
prendre c'est devenir plus libre et la
personne qui nous a appris ça bien voilà
c'est rosa parks rosa parks elle nous a
appris qu'on pouvait agir pour changer
le monde
elle a refusé de céder sa place à un
blanc dans un bus et en faisant ça elle
a créé le mouvement des droits civiques
avec un geste
bien voilà c'est ça que nous devons
faire aujourd'hui nous devons apprendre
changer le monde
en agissant nous avons le pouvoir au
creux de nos mains
nous avons le pouvoir d'acheter nous
avons le pouvoir de ne pas acheter
nous avons le pouvoir de faire changer
les choses alors ce pouvoir il faut
évidemment l'exercer on voit l'exercer
dans différents domaines de la vie
ce qui est important c'est la vie
quotidienne vie quotidienne elle passe
par des produits comme la lessive comme
les produits ménagers
ça passe aussi par l'alimentation manger
moins manger mieux moins de viande moins
de souffrance animale moins de
pesticides plus de produits naturels
moins de plastique moindre rejet
on peut aussi apprendre à fabriquer des
moteurs les moteurs à haut les moteurs à
huile
moteur à hydrogène ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas forcément besoin de banderoles
ni de manifester
faire signer des pétitions pour changer
le monde on a plutôt besoin d'agir et on
sera du côté des faisons est pas du côté
des cousines mais quand même dans un
monde où il ya beaucoup de couzou
et bien c'est à nous de devenir des feux
agissons et pour ça on doit redécouvrir
un produit qu'on tousse on l'a tous sur
nous il est économique écologique
le voilà c'est l'huile de coude
on doit apprendre à fabriquer des choses
allaient faire parce que apprendre à
faire c'est de venir plus libre à c'est
cette liberté que nous devons
redécouvrir
et la deuxième chose que nous devons
apprendre c'est à changer notre mental
parce que quand on fait des produits
s'est pas exactement comme ce qu'on
achète
tessi fonctionne très bien elle était
testée dans un laboratoire indépendant
du finistère
les mêmes résultats qu'une lessive du
commerce elle coûte 12 centimes d'euro
elle est faite avec uniquement des
produits naturels elle fonctionne
extrêmement bien et voilà
pour certaines personnes elle ne mousse
pas mousse pas assez il nous en occident
on aime la mousse la mousse c'est quoi
la mousse sa lave pas la mousse sont des
bulles
ils sont frappés du complexe dit car
elles montrent plus près de toi mon dieu
mais les boues ce boulet les mousses et
les bulles c'est quoi c'est de l'air
avec la grèce autour
nous on aime l'air avec la grèce autour
ça qu'on aime
quand elle arrive quand elle monte comme
ça on plus près de toi mon dieu c'est un
lego est gonflé bien entendu et un
moment donné les lois de la physique
vont s'appliquer elles sont impitoyables
les lois de la physique pression
extérieure va devenir plus forte la
pression intérieure paf
chaque bulle va éclater pourquoi je vous
raconte ça ce qu'est la pression
or c'est nous
et nous qui pouvons faire changer le
monde la pression qu'on peut exercer et
c'est de cette façon qu'on va passer de
la liberté à l'égalité on dit on n'est
pas dans une société
à égalité on est sur le pont nous sur le
pont d'un navire on sait même pas où il
va on n'est pas aux commandes on est sur
le pont et puis bon jour je lui tire la
corde là on essaye mon récit soral
s'indigne mais toute notre énergie passe
dans l'indignation
et si on lâche la corde les lois de la
physique vont s'appliquer elles sont
impitoyables en face patatras et nous on
reste debout sur le pont
voilà comment on va réussir à faire
changer le monde n'agit sens et en
lâchant la corde
ça c'est bien pour une égalité sociétal
maintenant l'égalité elle se gagne tous
les jours à la maison
j'aurais pu là
r avec de l'argile bleus de l'argile
rouge
coûte l'orgie de rose plutôt son était
stupide le rose depuis quelques années
depuis plusieurs années on repeint les
petites filles en rose suis pas pourquoi
la lessive n'est pas réservé aux femmes
les femmes ne sont pas des domestiques
les femmes ne sont pas des secrétaires
les femmes ne sont pas au service des
messieurs
égalité c'est tous les jours que ça se
conquiert et on est loin du compte on
est loin du compte on est loin du compte
on a plus de facilité à dénoncer le
monde a changé ses propres pratiques
regardez les nouveaux agriculteurs des
nouveaux paysans et nous font des
discours c'est magnifique
les discours qu'ils font sur le sol en
équilibre le sol ans et d'équilibré mais
sait-on équilibrer le travail à la
maison c'est une autre paire de manches
il y a quelqu'un qui malheureusement est
un bon exemple c'est morgane ce plouc
morgan spurlock c'est le réalisateur de
ce documentaire que vous avez peut-être
vu
documentaire sur la malbouffe il a été
beaucoup plus prompts à dénoncer la mal
bouffe changer ses propres pratiques
morgan spurlock présenté ses excuses aux
femmes qui la harcelait sexuellement
pendant des années
il a dit je fais partie du problème il a
raison il fait partie du problème mais
on fait tous partie du problème
tous pourquoi parce qu'on sait on dit
rien mais frappé par le syndrome de
l'administration française
pas de vagues disons non le silence
profite toujours aux bourreaux dans les
familles quand un enfant un ado subi des
violences sexuelles
s'il parle neuf fois sur dix il exclut
du foyer
ce chiffre comme moi c'est une
catastrophe un viol toutes les 7 minutes
en france une femme sur trois se déclare
harcelés au travail ça se passe ici
autour de nous chez nous on connaît les
victimes ou pire on les connaît pas
soyons du côté des victimes et pas du
côté du bo débourser les victimes qu'il
faut protéger les victimes c'est
malheureusement ont d'abord
évidemment il faut
communiqué il faut parler il faut faire
parler les enfants les jeunes des ados
il faut écouter
il faut aller voir la personne qui est
en arrêt maladie
peut-être allez lui poser des questions
qu'avait plus proche des gens c'est
important
et puis on changera le monde aussi par
l'éducation
la lessive n'est pas réservée où les
filles peuvent aussi apprendre des beaux
métiers d exercer les garçons peuvent
aussi savez ce tir dans la vie
domestique
c'est par l'éducation que les choses
changeront et celle affaire de tous
et en acquérant plus d'égalité on pourra
arriver à la fraternité ou à la sororité
nous avons une devise
au milieu de cette devise cool l'égalité
il n'y a pas de fraternité sans égalité
il n'y a pas de liberté sans égalité
alors la fraternité c'est magnifique
c'est un beau mot c'est un mot qu'on
pourrait
chez de l'humanisme la fraternité c'est
choisir d'être plutôt que d'avoir mené
dans un monde trop matérialiste vous le
savez le changer il faut choisir d'être
plutôt que d'avoir la personne qui nous
a montré
un exemple un exemple que j'admire
toujours encore aujourd'hui si nikola
tesla nikola tesla sera génial inventeur
il a inventé l'énergie libre gratuite
pour tous sur toute la planète depuis
150 ans ça existe bon il a vécu en même
temps qu'edison malheureusement pour lui
nikola tesla marie curie comme rené
quinton sont des humanistes qui ont
choisi d'être plutôt que d'avoir faisant
ça ils nous montrent on doit laisser
notre hôte côté que notre ego ne doit
pas être comme ces bulles vont de toute
façon éclater un jour doit être plutôt
qu'à voir
alors comment on fait dans la vie de
tous les jours chacun chez soi quel acte
peut faire concrètement
bien on continue ce qu'on fait ici et là
c'est à dire des associations comme ici
puis les journées de la gratuité c'est
magnifique
puis réparer mes trois vélos en faire un
et puis construire des meubles en
palettes par exemple et puissent
échanger des savoirs et puis créer des
monnaies locales tout ça ça existe c'est
merveilleux pour continuer il faut
continuer les fab lab faut se mettre
autour des voitures et des moteurs et y
construire des moteurs à haut c'est
important aujourd'hui puis de découvrir
les éoliennes les éoliennes plus tôt
plutôt horizontale faut qu'on s'y mette
tous faut qu'on continue et en faisant
ça on va pas perdre du temps vont gagner
ira moins dans les grandes surfaces ou
prendra moins de deux voitures
on dépensera autrement et puis on aura
plus de convivialité plus de solidarité
plus de fraternité
et en faisant ça on va gagner du temps
et en gagnant du temps va mettre ce
temps il faudrait mettre ce temps au
service de la nature parce que c'est là
d'où on vient parce qu'on est plus des
poussières que des étoiles ce qu'on doit
retrouver l'humilité
et l'humilité a la même racine que
l'humus
et ça qu'on va retrouver doit être
capable
s'émerveiller devant un flocon de neige
de vents les nuages qui passent qui se
font et qui se défont devant une rose
qui est clos devant les feuilles
d'arbres qui tombe avec ses belles
couleurs mordorées qu'on leur connaît
on doit être capable 2
s'émerveiller devant l'odeur du gazon
l'odeur de la terre après la pluie
c'est tout ça qui va nous aider à
retrouver ce lien sacré avec la nature
qui nous fait défaut aujourd'hui
alors pour terminer je dois vous
pourquoi j'ai appelé cette chronique
l'évolution quotidienne
figurez-vous devant un documentaire et
quelques temps chez moi
et ce documentaire expliqué qu'un homme
souhaitait créer son mouvement
utilisant ses initiales je me suis dit
waouh
si je devais faire pareil mais initiale
je suis mal parti
hercules faut les porter
les premiers mots qui me sont venues ce
les raviolis qui moi je me fignon je
préfère ça ça me ressemble pas ravioli
quiche
et en fait le mot révolution est arrivé
très vite
d'après le mot quotidienne est arrivé en
regardant les lessives tout simplement
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]